hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the escape it's I
have a plan and by that I mean I have a
trowel if that means that I have a plan
and you know what that's that's all I'll
tank because that's all I need you still
put that away
I can't acquit like oh it's a tool I
can't equip it that's right okay so with
this file I should be able to do stuff
with it
okay a hammer that seems incredibly
useful I have no money
damn it I need to find someone to beat
up that sounds like a very brutal thing
to say but it's true you need to either
way for someone to like going to someone
gonna come in the bathroom huh we're
good you gotta get some huh good Tom get
some No yeah yeah I did it
class shored oh yeah and wire hell yeah
alright that worked out very well in my
favor so what I just need to do now is I
just need to make sure that my ax my
pecs are in impeccable order I can
actually beat people up now pretty
effectively
so I beat people up I take their stuff I
don't need to use any money I just used
my brute strength to wall up them in the
face I don't even know who I beat up did
I beat up Danny oh no I feel bad if I
beat up Dania oh no that's Danny okay
Danny didn't get beat up
uh-oh who I beat up but I bet he
deserved it that's what I'm saying
Morgan bar beating up his friends 2015
that's my new year's resolution is here
alright okay so I wonder what my
strength is up to now wow I am really
strong 65 hell yeah oh I feel so good I
could beat up anybody now let me
actually go put my stuff away
I'm wondering how do I make that glass
yard into a weapon do I just I remember
I picked up something else but like back
before but I have to make a handle out
of it somehow I just don't know how so
there's got to be some other aspect of
this that I'm not fully into
understanding I'm gonna beat you up beat
up well this guy's tough how not that
tough though he's gone PACA playing cars
and an inmate outfit
why you just deserve that I don't know I
don't know if you did but wax this act
period is my jam I love exercise
exercise my favorite yeah got a workout
line yeah let's get sweaty
well all right jack good let me let me
bear with here we're all in prison we're
gonna be here awhile
you don't need to go shouting let's get
sweaty and everybody you know just let
everyone do their thing
you do your thing we don't need to know
what's going on training up to clip a
guard
you shouldn't [ __ ] y'all me match this
is guard literally right there you don't
need to shout that to the heavens you
know there's a lot of things that you do
besides shouting that to me I'm too
fatigued good oh god why in the middle
of everything gonna plan things man
lalalala lalalala lalalala slathering up
a do I need to distract during the
shower lock no a lot of churches no okay
I've been beating up random people I
just haven't been beating up the right
people wha la la la love what has been
seen can't be unseen oh yeah yamimash
how about some of this ship this ship
sale shipping this I don't know my
favorite place really robots really Ross
is it Ross
yeah gang something wrong Oh cinnamon on
could drive on this road forever advice
you know you're not in a on a road
you're you're in a shower with a bunch
of other men and do ger is a messed up
place is what prison will do to people
mess with their minds so I think I
needed to provide it no damn it I hate
these things
okay this sucks this sucks beat up Jack
and Danny oh I just need to beat up
someone you know what I'm not gonna stay
here I need to do it I'm not hungry at
all as far as I know I don't actually
need to eat I'm just gonna get more buff
and swole so that I can smack people
down actually I'm pretty sure this
doesn't actually improve my damage I
think it just improves how much damage I
can take which is good nonetheless
because I need to be able to more take
more if I'm gonna be able to oh no no no
you don't know where I am no you don't
know where I why were you here anyway
don't don't mess with me bro I'm I'm a
man on the edge all right anyway I have
a trial so tonight I'm gonna try to dig
my way out and if I can't well that's
just that good oh it's free time never
compete up this guy yeah but I'm gonna
beat up somebody else hey stop following
me screw going in the bathroom there
Jack it's time - I'm it's right back
take time map oh I needed to beat up
Jack
Oh sock yes a sponge a sock in a book
well you know Jack's priorities are good
but I can get a sock mace now just like
what the tutorial showed me to do I can
do things I can do things I can I'm
accomplishing things probably not
everyone out there's boiling oh yes mark
you you you did something good job there
Mark II knew but bear with me everyone I
want to make a sock mace
hey four more inch screw you with your
int I'll get four more in screw you
that's a bunch of baloney
what are too stupid to put a sock in a
sock what I can't figure it is when way
though huh dude you boys go okay fine
whatever
watch it use then of intelligence for
you am i sophisticated enough now too
much so oh that was very complicated yes
but I figured it out with my giant brain
I'm so bad
okay so I fine I need I'm gonna beat up
somebody else with this sock first you
you you you in the shower yeah Jack you
gonna get it again
you again for no tip oh why are these
two unconscious another trial I'll take
that plunger a teddy bear
I had a teddy bear before let's take
another one let me just drop all this
stuff off at my cell and then I'll just
be on my way that guy used to be a CEO
somehow I doubt that very much
okay so I got to trowels don't know what
they do but I got him
and I also got glass I got a whole bunch
of stuff I hope they don't check my cell
Danny get back home chef I can't help
you with that Danny it's almost time for
night roll call I need to get smarter I
need to increase my brain powers yeah I
can crap then get a gig even though the
tutorial chilled me that I needed to do
now never mind you know I'm gonna beat
up one more person before you
yummy match I'm so sorry this is what
this needs to happen it needed to happen
or your role of to hammer
Hellyeah hammer give me that ah yeah
Mass you're holding out on me who's
beating me in the face with a hammer but
I had my self in shock I really showed
him what for uh okay sure yeah I'll beat
somebody up need to beat up ego bum bum
and cinnamon Aman Aman officer Owen need
to be
oh and I don't think I'm gonna be able
to do that maybe I will
who knows one of the hammers a better
weapon than a sock at ease folks
I am so eased I'm easy eased following
her do to sell toss not me
bourbon Dirac is Europe good not me
something about all the cuts creep why
comb [ __ ] whatever prisoner is always
right
are they okay really I'm interesting
developments I'd like to commend you all
okay bye
okay I need to get into a position where
I can slip out relatively easily Oh God
Wow
oh no oh no what if I dig like right
here yeah I'm gonna tunnel out of this
bad boy what what happened what what is
that what is that what what digging the
light so I can see what I'm digging it
oh oh I need to dig more okay I think oh
my god I'm never gonna make it through
this oh no oh no oh no
damnit I think I need to create like a
dummy of myself god I lost my sock mace
oh god damn it this game is unforgiving
if you mess up a little bit you're gone
everything's just gone comb blade I'll
take it I got start over again get a
muffin I'll take that muffin and a
bottle of medicine so that when I de
energize myself from digging so much
stupid bull Oh cracking note oh yeah
gimme gimme gimme
cushioned inmate outfit oh so I can
create a diversion oh that's actually
really useful god damn it ah this game I
want to be good at it ah it's so hard so
hard oh so hard all right whatever I'll
take the razor blades I can create more
comb blades with them just equip this
one take the comb and barbs esque
create a comb bleed nasty dep create a
comb bleed not dead craft it up I'm
getting good at this getting good at
this I'm gonna beat up a goddamn up
officer you can wait up ah voila wool
wool up oh and you're done key yes give
work key okay am baton oh yeah you take
his muffin
that's for you not for you Stu that's
for you you still you do good okay Stu
muah love you sorry I bopped you in the
head with a chip a blade very deadly
sorry Barry dead infirmary bit I'm just
gonna say until I can heal up a little
bit more rest up ah what Oh Oh God
these guys they're smart they know when
a an officer has been bashed in the back
of the head and then thrown into jail I
am bad at this game I am thoroughly
terrible come here I want to beat you up
anyway uh so what needs to happen is
it's like what the clue said I need to
make a mold of the key which probably
means that I could Blake
we could probably somehow okay my my
thought process is that I could probably
somehow use soap to make a mold of the
key and in that way I would be able to
do what I need to get the key then put
the key back on his body he never knows
what hit him he totally forgives it I
hit him in the first place and
everything is hunky-dory I guess that's
my guess anyway cuz then I could have a
mold of the key and I could make I carve
it out a soap or something I don't know
it is not good stuff they're giving me
give me good stuff baby I gotta end this
episode soon dammit I got to record a
lot more for packs cuz my flight leaves
like in a few hours here they locked the
outside doors those used to be open the
screws right cuz I went out yeah Oh
magazine I'll take that yes be also
dirty and maid outfit ah Mathias and you
get no ill yeah what's the magazine yeah
huh yeah alright now now now an officer
comes by this way I'm gonna Bob him in
the head also I gotta borrow chocolate
and some hand cream
do I have any more did I put any more
weapons oom
yeah nah they took all my good stuff
goddamnit those damn bastards they took
all my good stuff ever
I can't believe muff heard muffins and I
can't believe muffins are contraband I
can't believe nails
Kandra man I still haven't been able to
do the goddamn thing with the goddamn
ceiling unless I didn't need like an
actual screwdriver to be able to do that
maybe I could have done it with
something else
I don't know nope I don't know I don't
know man I don't know anymore
the place is gone in my head I'm so dumb
you're gonna get beat the [ __ ] up cuz of
cus Wade damnit goddamn away oh I'm so
terrible I'm so bad I feel bad oh my god
I'm just an embarrassment I apologize
guys I'm so bad I'm gonna end this here
just two for your guys's sake I hope you
enjoyed it nonetheless like I had a lot
of fun playing it even though I did so
terribly if I ever do play this again
I'm gonna do it knowing what I'm doing I
apologize I just had to throw myself
into recording cuz of packs and whatever
you're seeing this in the future either
way thank you for putting up with my
terrible [ __ ] if that's any
consolation
vent vent away in the comments just vent
all you want this is your free period in
the comments below tell me how terrible
I was at this game tell me all the
things I could have done differently
all the things that could have changed
it was a learning experience this is
your moment
unleash release all your tension release
all your stress like a flock of doves
pretty
and let me know how badly I did thank
you again everybody summer for watching
click the end the days of all videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
Ivan found the key you smell a key
around here
you smell key find those boxes boxes
that bullied you look smaller oh look at
this tiny box oh it's so tiny oh I'm
gonna call you tiny box Tim you're gonna
come with me on an adventure tiny box
Tim